في سيده من جنوب افريقيا اسمها مونديليا
وعمرها 36 سنه عايشه من كذا سنه في
نيوزيلندا مع اسرتها واطفالها ولما قدمت
على اقامه دائمه طلبها ان رفض للاسف ولحون
القصه عادي وبتصير لا يعني لا كثير ناس
لكن الجزئيه الغريبه هي في سبب الرفض
الحكومه نيوزلنديه رافضه طلب الاقامه بسبب
وزن السيد الزائد وقالت لها لو بدك تضلي
عايشه في نيوزيلندا وتاخدي اقامه لازم
تنزلي وزنك 30 كيلو او تغادر الاراضي
المنزليه اول مره باسمعه بصراحه
حسب المستندات الرسميه انه وزنها زائد هذا
راح يخليها للامراض اكثر وللمشاكل الصحيه
وبالتالي ممكن تشكل عيده على النظام الصحي
في نيوزيلندا كل نيوزيلندا راح يصير عبء
من سيده واحده يعني زائد وزنها على كل حال
منزلينا هوزنها تقريبا 130 كيلو
واستئنا فات على القرار واخذت اعفاء
واقامه بعد ما نزلت وزنها ونسبه الدهون في
جسمها حوالي 10 نقاط واستغلت اللي صار
لبدا رحله لانزال الوزن وبتشاركها مع
متابعيها على حساباتها وبتتمرن خمس مرات
في الاسبوع لكن من هون لوقتها يبدو انها
حابه تستفيد من الدرج الاعلاميه اللي
يعملها الموضوع واعلانات مؤخرا لانها راح
تبدا في العمل كعارضه ازياء كمان من
صاحبات الوزن الزائد
[موسيقى]